the Joe Rogan experience yeah I mean
there's not a lot of places like that
anymore because people have find those
places and [ __ ] them up and
overpopulated them but there's a few of
them left you just got to deal with
extreme weather the extreme weather is
the barrier for [ __ ] it keeps them
out you think so yeah moving the [ __ ]
Montana it's hard that's why we just
tried to buy a Greenland yes got shot
down well I think you see his [ __ ]
post where he said I promised not to do
this and he showed a picture of
Greenland with a giant Trump Tower I
like this guy's funny
he might be an [ __ ] people might hate
them they might might be a problem as a
president bla bla bla bla bla you can't
deny that occasionally he is [ __ ]
hilarious no it is funny and I think
that people try there's certain people
that try hard to not see the humor in it
yes I've retweeted it I was like get on
with your bad self mr. Trump oh look I
don't read my Twitter posts I'm sure a
bunch of people got mad at me for that
but I don't read it I just post and
forget it I just get out of Dodge I just
leave little packages and then get the
[ __ ] out of that it was fine about that
picture that I found myself
zooming in trying to see what those
people in those houses had going on oh
no these guys look great they probably
hunt well reading that has so much
natural resources and it's also probably
a place it's gonna be an awesome spot to
live in a hundred years when the [ __ ]
rest the world's on fire maybe I'll wind
up there man
yeah well muskox we were talking about
that yesterday muskox
Jamie pulled up a thing a statistic on
monk socks muskox that the success rate
for bow hunting is 100% in some units
yeah in Greenland
oh okay 100% in Greenland because you
know they huddle you know they huddle up
to protect themselves against wolves so
they just stay in a spot when they see a
threat which is great for wolves but not
so good for projectiles
yeah and I've hunted them before yeah
apparently they're delicious Brendan
Byrne said that they taste like the best
Kobe beef yeah it's really tough but
good and marbled yeah